el estadio jalifa de la bienvenida a los
octavos de final de esta copa mundo de
Qatar 2022 una fase que comienza con una
enorme diversidad ocho equipos europeos
3 de la confederación asiática 13 del
continente americano y dos africanos una
selección de 16 combinados nacionales
que a su vez representa a cinco
continentes porque aunque con la
confederación asiática hay tres equipos
una cifra récord para esta confederación
Uno de ellos es Australia que ante la
FIFA compite con Asia pero pertenece a
Oceanía por parte de América figura en
Estados Unidos Argentina y Brasil estos
dos últimos los únicos representantes
del balompié latinoamericano mención
especial merece la eliminación de México
en la fase de grupos algo que no pasaba
desde hace 44 años ninguna selección
consiguió pleno de victorias consiguió
los nueve puntos en esta primera
instancia algo que no ocurría desde la
copa mundo de 1994 además todos los
equipos ya han encajado goles para las
casas de apuestas Pese a que son minoría
los dos equipos latinoamericanos siguen
siendo Los favoritos para llevarse el
trofeo aquí en Qatar Brasil y Argentina